je vous rappelle que lors de sa réunion
du 17 novembre 2022 la délégation
sénatoriale aux outre-mer a décidé
d'inscrire dans son programme de travail
2023 une étude sur la continuité
territoriale que Catherine Concorde la
Martinique et Guillaume chevrolier de la
Mayenne ont été désignés rapporteur
nous engageons donc ce matin une série
d'auditions consacrée à ce sujet à
l'initiative de nos rapporteurs nous
inaugurons nos travaux avec l'examen du
dispositif de continuité territoriale
avec la Corse dont l'objet est
précisément de réduire les contraintes
de l'insularité mise en oeuvre en 1976
pour les liaisons maritimes fuit
étendues en 1979 aux liaison aériennes
ce dispositif et figure de modèle compte
tenu de son ancienneté et de ses
modalités gérer d'abord par l'État puis
par la collectivité territoriale de
Corse devenue en 2018 collectivités de
Corse nous avons sans doute beaucoup à
apprendre sur son fonctionnement à la
fois sur ces réussites et peut-être
aussi sur ces réalité cet échange est
donc particulièrement opportun pour nous
car une de nos préoccupations est
d'améliorer le système actuel pour les
outre-mer et de tirer les enseignements
de ce précédent Corse pour approfondir
nos connaissances sur la gestion du
dispositif nous avons successivement
pour la collectivité de Corse madame
Flora Mattei conseillère exécutive soyez
la bienvenue pour l'Office des
transports de Corse l'OTC Monsieur
Patrick Antonetti responsable des
départements aériens et maritimes soyez
bienvenue également puis nous
accueillerons les éclairages des
opérateurs pour Air France Monsieur
Aurélien Gomez on charge des relations
institutionnelles et Madame Meriem Twizy
directrice des affaires territoriales
pour Air Corsica monsieur Luc bérini
président du directoire et pour Corsica
Linéa Monsieur Pierre Antoine Vilanova
directeur général et enfin pour la
meilleure qui devrait nous rejoindre si
j'ai bien compris monsieur Marc
Reverchon son président
mesdames messieurs nous vous remercions
bien évidemment vivement de votre
disponibilité vous allez avoir la parole
à tour de rôle et dans l'ordre que je
viens dénoncer s'il vous plaît pour une
dizaine de minutes chacun afin de
présenter vos observations préliminaires
vous appuierez bien évidemment sur la
trame de questionnaire qui vous a été
adressé par la délégation pour vous
aider dans cette audition et ensuite je
donnerai la parole à nos deux
rapporteurs qui interviendront pour vous
demander des précisions et enfin à mes
collègues sénateurs qui sont parmi nous
également pour vous interpeller le code
échéant sur les questions qui seraient
pendantes je vous laisse donc la parole
dans l'ordre que je viens d'énoncer je
laisse maintenant la parole à Madame
Flora Mattei
bien est-ce que vous m'entendez
correctement parfaitement parfait alors
je vais pouvoir commencer j'ai l'honneur
vraiment de
d'introduire cette table ronde alors
c'est une très très grande question que
la continuité de service public et de la
continuité territoriale surtout quand
nous sommes un territoire insulaire cher
messieurs dames chers sénateur cher
rapporteur je vous remercie de vous être
posé ces questions qui sont des
questions fondamentales justement pour
la réduction des dépendances par rapport
donc du coup aux importations de fait du
simple fait de l'insularité mais aussi
de la de la réduction
des contraintes de l'insularité je parle
du développement économique vous savez
que une île ne fonctionne pas de la même
façon que n'importe quel région
continentale et donc du coup il y a
aussi apprendre en compte dans
l'organisation de la desserte aérienne
et la desserte maritime de ces
territoires qu'ils soient métropolitain
ou
ultra périphériques en tout cas des
enjeux majeurs de développement pour
leur ville et pour donc les
développements économiques
environnementaux sociétaux majeures dans
le contexte que nous connaissons qui est
un contexte particulièrement complexe
avec des crises successives crises
sanitaire crise économique crise sociale
depuis très très peu de temps justement
crise aussi géopolitique à
l'international avec une guerre en
Ukraine à quelques encablures de nos
territoires donc un contexte global très
important dans un contexte aussi
concurrentiel il faut le dire au niveau
européen particulièrement strictes avec
une harmonisation de fait du droit
interne du droit communautaire qui nous
permettent donc de pouvoir baser le plus
possible et consolider les différentes
desserts de services publics pour la
continuité territoriale aussi bien des
passagers que des marchandises car vous
avez aussi que les territoires
insulaires pour la plupart et je parle
pour ma paroisse mais c'est vrai que
pour asile nous dépendons beaucoup
d'importations du fret des continents
quels qu'ils soient donc des objectifs
majeurs alors je voudrais juste revenir
un petit peu sur
les objectifs et les principes du
conseil exécutif de Corse dans le cadre
de cette continuité territoriale et donc
la collectivité de Corse pour permettre
et organiser nous sommes donc une
autorité d'élégante et donc autorité qui
nous permet d'organiser de statuer sur
la desserte maritime et aérienne de la
Corse entre la Corse et le continent et
à ce titre de la dotation de continuité
territoriale qui nous permet d'abonder
certaines compensations il y a de les
compensations d'exploitation
d'investissement de carburant qui nous
permet donc de venir
donner donc du corps et de la structure
a donc ces délégations de services
publics
donc avec toujours en tête les exigences
droit interne droit communautaire comme
je vous disais pourquoi
mettre en place ces liens ces liaisons
pour définir aussi un périmètre de
service public qui correspond aux
besoins et aux intérêts des Corses de
l'accord de ce territoire insulaire
métropolitain avec donc une dotation
d'un service de qualité un coût le plus
maîtrisé possible un système
économiquement et socialement le plus
vertueux avec aussi l'intégration et on
est dans un contexte en ce moment avec
une crise climatique qui est très très
importante donc la maîtrise aussi des
intégrations des enjeux de la transition
écologique elle est fondamentale et le
développement durable pour la Corse le
tout donc dans un cadre comme je le
disais le plus sécurisé au plan
juridique
revenons donc sur
les éléments qui nous permettent aussi
de pouvoir assurer et de pouvoir être
l'autorité d'élégante c'est à dire celle
qui organise la desserte maritime et
aérienne entre l'accord et le continent
nous avons de l'État nous percevons une
dotation de continuité territoriale
alors juste pour prendre un exemple très
simple si nous nous basons sur l'année
2023 nous avons une répartition à peu
près de 107 millions d'euros pour les 5
routes maritimes pour la desserte
maritime et à peu près 90 millions
d'euros pour les quatre routes pour les
quatre aéroports donc avec les 12 routes
donc c'est à dire le bord à bord Nice
Marseille et Paris qui nous permet donc
de faire en sorte que des passagers
puissent en tout cas rejoindre là en
Corse ou partir de Corse pour se faire
soigner pour aller travailler pour aller
faire des études sur le continent
par ces 12 euros et donc pour le service
aérien donc nous sommes sur une
compensation d'environ 90 millions
d'euros
en 2023
il faut savoir aussi que nous avons des
spécificités géographiques très
importantes et c'est pour ça que nous
avons donc des infrastructures
aéroportuaires et portuaires qui sont
nombreuses l'accord se répond à un
statut d'il montagne donc il est plus
facile de desservir l'accord par la mer
en termes de fret et de marchandises
d'acheminement que par
l'interpénétration de par depuis un port
principal vers les différentes villes
pour la distribution dans chacun dans
chacune des micro-résions de notre île
de la même façon les infrastructures
aéroportuaires sont au nombre de 4 donc
4 2 aéroports principaux de
complémentaires qui nous permettent
aussi d'absorber un certain flux nous
avons il y a très très peu justement
subi aussi
un contrôle de la part de la Cour des
comptes avec une enquête de la chambre
régionale des comptes qui nous permet
aussi d'être plus comment dirais-je
[Musique]
dans une sécurité dans une visée de
sécurisation des infrastructures
aéroportuaires car justement nous avons
les quatre infrastructures
aéroportuaires qui qui sont enfin en
tout cas qui ont été démontrées post
covid avec la relance avec les éléments
qui nous permettent aujourd'hui de dire
que malgré le chamboulement du secteur
des transports malgré le chamboulement
du secteur comment dire de la logistique
post covid avec la relance qui a été
particulièrement difficile il était donc
impensable pour nous qu'il n'y ait plus
ou qu'il y ait vraiment une remise en
cause de ces infrastructures et le
rapport donc de la Cour des comptes nous
conforte en ce sens car nous avons donc
la possibilité maintenant de dire que
les aéroports et les infrastructures et
les plateformes
aéroportuaires de la Corse ont très bien
réagi et ont pu justement rebondir face
à la crise
voilà donc un besoin très important
surtout pour une maîtrise alors là je
partirai aussi bien pour le maritime que
pour l'aérien sur la maîtrise des
paramètres à partir à partir du moment
où en fait on a un établissement du
besoin de service public
le besoin de service public nous l'avons
alors pour le maritime par exemple lors
de la DSP 2023 2029 que nous avons mis
en place l'année dernière et qui a pris
donc a été mise en service à partir du
1er janvier 2023 nous avons donc du
diligenté des tests de marché
particulièrement rigoureux spécifique
qui sont conformes en tout cas au droit
européen qui sont très très inspirés
d'ailleurs des questionnaires de
d'autres dessertes de Méditerranée
occidentale que nous avons eu
et donc qui nous ont permis aussi de
renforcer les différents
questionnaires et donc et les différents
tests de marché que nous avons
diligentés pour le maritime sur ces
points là ce qui est très très important
aussi de noter c'est que les
consultations aussi bien des usagers que
des compagnies ont été faites dans les
règles de l'art ce qui nous permet en
fait d'avoir aussi une identification
plus précise du besoin de service public
au départ de la Corse et à destination
donc pour le maritime de Marseille et
pour demain pour l'aérien pour un
périmètre géographique qui ce qui est
encore à définir
donc ça c'était des travaux qui nous ont
permis aussi il faut le dire de
conforter de renforcer les bases
économiques factuelles par rapport aux
différentes DSP et que c'est là que vous
parlez aussi des difficultés que l'on
avait pu rencontrer par ailleurs avec
les prises en compte des problématiques
de saturation notamment pour le fret et
ça nous n'avions pas vraiment objectiver
par le passé chose qui est faite
aujourd'hui ainsi que donc la desserte
de marchandises au point de vue de la
régularité de la fréquence et de la
sécurité
donc l'intérêt aussi d'une maîtrise de
cet enjeu stratégique donc des
transports pour une île nous a permis
aussi de stabiliser un certain nombre de
paramètres
dans le domaine des transports de la
logistique mais donc à destination des
résidences pour ne citer que quelques
exemples je ne prendrai par exemple que
la tailleification du fret qui est
maîtrisée aujourd'hui et ce malgré
justement le côté très très fluctuant et
très inflationniste des carburants que
nous avons et que nous subissons et que
chaque citoyen peut
avoir vraiment et voir conceptualiser
dans sa vie au quotidien donc sans
indexation sur le cours du carburant et
avec une mise en oeuvre d'ailleurs d'un
contrat de couverture carburant qui
permet donc de fixer la tarification
donc compensation
carburant
tout en améliorant d'ailleurs la qualité
du service
donc le tarif pour le fret dans le cadre
de ces conventions de délégation de
service public avait été défini
conformément donc a une méthode
équivalente routier donc ce qui veut
dire que on est exactement comme si nous
avions une traduction opérationnelle par
exemple pour le maritime entre Marseille
et les différents ports de Corse comme
si nous avions en gros des autoroutes et
que nous avions donc un équivalent
routier entre le quai de Marseille donc
le quai continental et le quai les quais
de Corse donc c'est vraiment cette
traduction opérationnelle qui nous
fallait pour le fret avec un objectif de
continuité territoriale entre la Corse
et le continent ce qui nous permet
d'être dans notre bon droit et d'avoir
aussi surtout une exigence politique
sans fragiliser les contrats de
délégation de service public pour une
éventuelle distorsion de concurrence si
nous aussi nous gardions par exemple les
tarifs qui seraient inférieurs à ce
tarif routier donc ça c'est le premier
paramètre que je voulais citer pour
vraiment montrer la maîtrise de la
stabilité grâce à ses délégations de
services publics grâce à ces contraintes
il y a aussi donc comme je le disais la
couverture carburant à 24 mois c'est à
dire qu'on arrive à demander à nos
compagnies délégataires de service
public de négocier aux meilleurs prix
des couvertures carburant pour nous
permettre tout simplement d'éviter les
phénomènes de sous-charge et de
surcharge d'une ne serait-ce que à
l'inflation et donc à la flambée des
prix des carburants donc ça c'est très
très important car par le passé nous
n'avions pas forcément
statué sur ce point précis c'est quelque
chose qui est maintenant intégré dans
les contrats et qui fonctionne très bien
ensuite
il est toujours à destination des
résidents
nous avons mis en place une mise donc
les tarifs exports qui permettent en
gros d'inciter les entreprises les
exploitations agricoles corses pour
justement envoyer à l'export avec donc
des tarifications préférentiels qui
permettent vraiment de pouvoir
avoir une vision qui nous permette donc
du coup un de manière incitative à
produire plus sur place à avoir plus de
proximité et à pouvoir donc justement
faire ces échanges entre l'accord et le
continent sur les exports également et
non pas sur le tout importe comme nous
avions jusqu'à présent
enfin et non des moindres
la tarification relative justement au
passager résident Corse la tarification
qui est très importante vous le savez
car justement il y a quelques années
nous avons pu réaliser des économies qui
étaient des économies très importantes
sur une
un rationne une rationalisation très
très importante de la datation de
continuité territoriale qui nous permet
donc en plus de dégager certains
reliquates et les reliquats ont pu être
donc mis à profit pour certaines
tarifications spécifiques alors je pense
à la tarification
résidente Corse qui nous permet de
diminuer la part que les
usagers corses mettent dans le transport
aérien pour pouvoir voyager pour
travailler pour aller faire des études
pour aller
ne serait-ce que pour aller se faire
soit soigner sur le continent de la même
une façon qui a des contraintes
géographiques très fortes encore il n'y
a absolument pas de CHU et donc du coup
de traitement spécifique vont devoir
être faits sur le continent et donc du
coup il y a vraiment un intérêt très
important pour tous les passagers de
pouvoir avoir une régularité une
fréquence
mensuelle et hebdomadaire pour pour
certains vols
journaliers pour les vols vers vers
Paris vers le bord à bord je rentrerai
pas forcément dans les détails par
rapport à ces périmètres là et c'est
volumes avec les différentes cadences
mais tout ça pour vous dire que ça fait
partie aussi des de la qualité de
service public et ça fait partie de
notre
intérêt nous à la collectivité de corps
c'est l'Office des transports de pouvoir
vraiment consolider ces périmètre là
donc pour ce qui est aussi des
spécificités d'autres comme vous le
savez les conventions de délégation de
service service public sont des
conventions qui sont plus contraignantes
pour le no délicateur de service public
qu'il soit dans l'aérien ou dans le
maritime et qui donc comme ce sont des
conventions qui qui contraignent qui
arrivent à obliger par rapport aux
fréquences par rapport aux horaires par
rapport à la qualité que l'on exige par
rapport à au verdissement des flottes
sur la qualité environnementale que l'on
souhaite attacher à certains navires ou
à certains engins ça nous permet aussi
d'avoir cette maîtrise justement de
l'outil qui va pouvoir être le vecteur
de transport entre la Corse et le
continent voilà j'espère que je n'ai pas
été particulièrement longue je voulais
quand même faire cette introduction
quelques propos sur justement les points
forts et les écueils qu'il a fallu
vraiment que l'on conforte alors
évidemment ça passe à l'Office des
transports et à la collectivité de Corse
par un dialogue permanent avec les
instances étatiques et les instances
européennes je pense au secrétariat
général des affaires européennes pour
le côté état je pense également à la
représentation permanente de la France à
Bruxelles pour le côté donc justement
transition justement entre les Français
et la Commission européenne je pense
aussi au ministère des Transports avec
des discussions sur les périmètres sur
les volumes sur les infrastructures et
aussi bien sûr il faut le dire aux
différentes directions générales de la
Commission européenne à la concurrence
au transport donc de la Commission
européenne voilà voilà un petit peu pour
ce panorama que je voulais quand même
faire et je laisserai la parole donc à
Monsieur santone et directeur de
l'Office des transports pour revenir
vraiment sur les fondamentaux de la
délégation de service public donc c'est
conventions de délégation de service
public très importante pour nous après
justement de stabiliser le plus possible
dans le cadre maximum de sécurité
juridique sur les
rien que dans le maritime et je vous
remercie à tous pour votre patience et
pour votre attention
en Tonetti s'il vous plaît à vous la
parole
oui bonjour je vais vous permettez
laissez la parole à notre directeur
général
donc Monsieur Jean-François
allez-y je vous en prie
bonjour à tous
sénateurs mes différents participants à
cette à ce webinaire d'État de la titre
dossier d'une approche conduite
territoriale pour les pour les autres
mères
moi je vais être un peu plus
technique c'est à dire dans
des paramètres qui sont économiques
financiers et juridiques
tout d'abord le dispositif de continuité
territoriale applicable à la Corse le
dispositif de continuité territoriale
applicable à la course c'est cohabiter
le secteur maritime du secteur
bénéfiction d'une quantité sectoriale en
terme de service public marketing en
termes de service public aérien avec une
différence importante car nous avons à
la base des obligations de services
publics du fait qu'elles ne peuvent pas
être assurées indépendant
physiquement par l'opérateur privé nous
allons vers des conventions de
délégation de service public tant dans
le secteur maritime que dans le secteur
alerte avec une différence importante
dans la mesure ou dans le secteur
maritime il y a une cohabitation entre
obligation de service public et
délégation service public alors que dans
aérien nous avons uniquement les
délégation de service public avec une
exclusivité d'exploitation aux bénéfice
du délicataire qui bénéficie d'un
convention sur les lignes relevant
d'obligation de service public
sur le maritime donc nous avons une
cohabitation
entre les obligations de service public
qui sont assurés depuis le port de
Toulon à destination des ports de Corse
par un opérateur privé à ce qui risque
été vite cela veut dire qu'il n'y a pas
de condensation mais également du port
de Nice en l'état et qui semblerait que
le port de Nice en quelques mois voire
24 mois sera fermé au trafic Jules Ferry
dans votre conséquence les obligations
en ce qui concerne les conventions de
délégation de service public elles sont
assurées par deux compagnies
délégataires au départ de quatre ports
de Corse à destination du port de
Marseille qui est le corps élevible aux
conventions de délégation se port
éligible ce n'est pas la collectivité
territoriale il a imposé
c'est les études de besoin de service
public que l'on a lancé qui pour des
intérêts par du fait de l'implantation
de la chaîne logistique de la capacité
portuaire par rapport au volume à
traiter pour la Corse était le plus
pertinent au regard des intérêts et
surtout du principe de continuité de
service public d'accord ne peut pas
subir de rupture de charge en termes
d'approvisionnement et pour le maritime
essentiellement sur le fret je vous
donne un chiffre nous avons 2 millions
de mètres linéaires de frais de
transporter chaque année entre les
différents corps de Corse et de
continent et vice versa un million
900000 transportés environ depuis le
port de Marseille et environ 150
000 mètres linéaires sont transportés
depuis le port depuis le port de Toulon
donc nous avons une
une complémentarité entre le
sosp et
les conventions délégation cellules en
ce qui concerne le mari il faut savoir
également que les obligations service
public sur le maritime sont
essentiellement
utilisés pour le transport de passage vu
que la compagnie délégataire pendant la
compagnie bénéficiant des obligations de
service public et s'inscrivant dans ces
politiques assure 85% du trafic passager
maritime à destination de la Corse les
compagnies bénéficiant de conventions de
délégation de service public assure 15%
du trafic passager maritime à deux et
vers la Corse et après on comprendra de
pourquoi quand je parlerai de
présenterai
en ce qui concerne ce service public
maritime vous comprendrez fort bien
qu'il a assez essentiellement sur le
frais avec trois types de frais et cet
élément est fondamental aujourd'hui nous
avons ce qu'on appelle le fret non
tracté qui est la remorque était chargée
pour faire simple parler docquières et
qui représente 90% du trafic de frais à
destination de la Corse
ensuite le pourcentage de frais
tracter lui qui est assuré par un ou la
remorque est tractée
par un par un tracteur géré par un
camion avec son chauffeur représente 10
à 15% du trafic frais à destination de
la course donc là aussi on se rend
compte que l'essentiel du trafic frais
obéit à la règle du non tractée avec
toute une problématique de mise à
disposition espace c'est-à-dire de
plateforme logistique sur les sur le
port de dessert et sur les deux ports
d'arrivée et de départ mais également de
forts ou de manutention pour ce type de
frais c'est une spécificité de la chaîne
logistique que nous intégrons tellement
dans le cadre des conventions que l'on a
mis que l'on a mis en place
en ce qui concerne l'aérien maintenant
l'aérien dont nous avons dit 12 lignes
de services publicitaires
à destination de trois plateformes
continentales Marseille et Nice mais
également l'aéroport de Paris
là aussi c'est pleinement le principe de
continuité territoriale qui s'applique
en matière aérienne dans beaucoup
pourraient dire ça n'intéresse que le
port à bord c'est-à-dire la liaison
encore
première côte du continent français
de Nice pour autant dans le cas du
principe de continuité territoriale nous
devons te permettre aux résidents corses
et quel que soit l'activité c'est-à-dire
loisirs économique sanitaire de pouvoir
se rendre dans la capitale à la fois
pour
des séances de travail mais également du
loisirs
de présence dans certains centres
médicaux spécialisés donc la desserte de
Paris aussi bien que celle de Marseille
et de Nice obéit au principe de service
public et gérer dans le cas des
conventions de délégation
c'est que deux mots dans les conventions
de délégation à ces études en tel
endroit à inversement de compensation
comme à évoqué madame madame la
Présidente il est certain qu'on a un
fort contrôle de ces de l'exécution des
conventions de délégation de
terme
d'exécution mensuelle c'est-à-dire avec
la fourniture de rapport d'activité de
séance de travail
contractualisé
tout au long de la vie de la vie du
contrat et avec un rapport d'activité
audité par un commissaire aux comptes
qui nous permet une certification des
comptes et le versement ou pas des
soldes de compensation
les montants de compensation de services
publics quels qu'ils sont
contractualisés sont des montants
maximum de compensation c'est-à-dire que
la convention sauf qu'à deux forces
majeure ou théorie de l'imprévision
comme nous avons dû l'appliquer lors de
la période covid se font au risque
zutrines du télégrate
qui sont très encadrés qui sont soumis
aux règles du coin interne et du droit
communautaires qu'on discute très en
amont avec les différents services de
l'État mais également et
obligatoirement avec les services de la
Commission européenne et puis quand il y
aura la difficulté concurrence qui est
dans le cadre des aides des aides
relatifs à la réglementation sur les
aides d'État
en ce qui concerne maintenant le montant
de dotation la dotation
dans le cadre de la loi de finance et
qui n'a plus été indexé depuis 2009 donc
nous avons obtenu cette année une
rallonge de 33 millions d'euros au titre
de la loi de finance
2 c'est 33 millions d'euros
correspondent au montant d'indexation
entre 2009 et 2020
nous allons maintenant entamer les
négociations pour essayer de stabiliser
ce nouveau complément de compensation
afin de faire face au dépenses de
continuité territoriale car pour l'année
2023 nous avons environ 95 millions
d'euros sur l'aérien et 107 millions
d'euros sur le maritime donc vous rendez
bien compte que les que le montant de
dotation initiale de 187 devient
insuffisant pour faire face aux dépenses
de service de service public
la règle qui a été celle de l'exécutif
territoriale et à travers le vote de
l'Assemblée de Corse pour le maritime
c'est assuré une qualité de service aux
résidents en termes de garantie de décès
avec le continent français c'est inscrit
comme tel dans le coach général des
collectivités territoriales tant en
matière d'accès c'est-à-dire je peux
partir de Corse
plusieurs fois par jour vers une
destination du
avec une plage horaire qui me permet de
faire mes affaires sur le continent et
de rentrer le soir en Corse donc on a en
moyenne sur le sur l'aérien trois
liaisons par jour entre les deux
aéroports principaux de Corse de Bastia
et d'Ajaccio à destination de la ville
de Marseille et de Paris Orly 2 sur Nice
je parle en programme de base on va pas
rentrer dans le saison était saison
hiver et
ensuite depuis les aéroports en
secondaire nous avons une liaison
quotidienne un minimum entre les
aéroports secondaires de Cali et qualité
et Figari à destination de Marcel église
boire deux et une liaison depuis ces
aéroports vers Paris donc la Corse avec
le système de service public en
narrative est parfaitement connecté au
continent en termes de fréquence
d'offres en siège
élément est important c'est à dire qu'on
a quasiment la garantie pour le résident
de partir de pouvoir partir quand il
veut à destination de ces trois
infrastructures et également de
régularité et de qualité de service
de la part de nos prestataires que ce
soit sur le maritime comme si on est
et qui ont mis les moyens qu'il fallait
et qui correspondaient aux attentes de
l'autorité des dépenses moyens
d'ailleurs il ne ces évoluer en termes
de qualité d'outils que ce soit dans le
maritime comme dans l'aérien pour les
deux compagnies maritimes et les deux
compagnies
[Musique]
sur le maritime ce qui était important
pour nous c'est de garantir la
cheminement fret quotidien de la Corse
car la Corse ne dispose pas de zone
logistique de stock même pour ces
produits de première nécessité que sont
les produits alimentaires 95 % des
produits nécessaires à la population
corse sont importés depuis le continent
français que ce soit en termes de
consommation courante de matériaux de
construction étaient pour ainsi dire de
l'ensemble des biens de consommation ça
fasse par la voie Marie de même que les
médicaments maintenant le cheminement
des médicaments à quelques exceptions
près passe également par la voie
maritime donc vous comprenez pour nous
l'importance qui avait à sécuriser ce
service public maritime en termes de
chair de logistique et principaux de
corps d'Ajaccio et de Bastia sont des
services quotidiennement 7 jours sur 7
par les compagnies délégatées les ports
secondaires de Propriano portové et
l'Île Rousse sont desservées trois fois
par semaine tout au long de l'année il
faut préciser que le port de l'île
Rousse est également un port dédié au
transport de matière dangereuses de
catégoriens catégorie de catégories les
matières dangereuses n'étant pas
uniquement
le comportant également
l'approvisionnement d'oxygène médical et
en chlore le chlore est nécessaire pour
le fonctionnement de l'ensemble des
stations d'épuration et pas uniquement
pour pour les piscines et donc pour le
voisin
là aussi
les volumes de Fred qui ont été définis
au besoin de service public l'ont été à
partir des différentes études de besoin
c'est-à-dire que nous n'avons pas
proposé une assemblée de Corse n'a pas
décidé
d'instaurer ce nombre de fréquences
c'est être linéaire nécessaire
d'un claquement de doigts
ça repose sur les besoins réels de la
population
en ce qui concerne maintenant les
tarifications pour le volet tarif
votre questionnaire fait état de tarifs
préférentiel aujourd'hui en ce qui
concerne l'application du principe de
continuité territoriale que ce soit en
équipe dans l'aérien pour les passagers
nous avons un tarif résident et non pas
un tarif
précédentielle et qui est véritablement
installé comme un tarifié aux résident
sur le bon rapport sur le bord à bord en
matière aérien en matière aérienne c'est
à dire vers les aéroports de Marseille
ce tarif est de 42 euros hors taxes
qui nous permet un atterrissage en TTC
de 100 euros ce qui veut dire que le
montant des taxes est supérieur au tarif
que paye le risque c'est un point quand
même d'interrogations important et là
j'évoque ce tarif avant l'impact des
nouvelles taxes
2024 voire 2023 imposé par la loi climat
et résiste en ce qui concerne le tarif
président sur Paris depuis les aéroports
de Corse c'est-à-dire par et de Paris
vers les aéroports de force pour les
résidents nous sommes sur un tarif de
150 euros avec là aussi aller-retour là
aussi un montant de taxes supérieur au
montant du tarif quasiment supérieur en
montant du tarif
en ce qui concerne le maritime la
présidente a évoqué bien sûr
présenter le tarif frais maritime ce
tarif traite maritime qui a compté du
1er janvier 23 de 40 euros hors taxes et
redevance le maître linéaire et
légèrement de ça les tarifs ok donc
distance
tel qu'il est appliqué et tel qu'il est
en conformité avec le principe de
continuité territoriale nous avons
poussé plus loin la réflexion afin de
garantir ce tarif dans pour le
consommateur final que pour les
différences entre entreprises en le
l'adossant à un contrat de couverture
carburant c'est-à-dire que contrairement
à ce qui se faisait dans les contrats
précédents avant le premier octobre 2019
il est arrivé subissaient la fluctuation
des peaux carburants bien souvent
toujours à la hausse jamais voir
inexistant la baisse aujourd'hui on a
une stabilité du tarif à 40 euros le
maître linéaire quel que soit l'impact
carburant sur bien sûr qui se procure
devient complètement dénaturé nous
remettons autour de la
en ce qui concerne maintenant les
relations avec la Commission européenne
et la question 6 plus particulièrement
c'était prononcé sur ce dispositif
les contrats de délégation en fait sur
l'aérien
ont tous été notifié à la Commission
européenne depuis les années depuis
l'année
2016 c'est-à-dire la délégation de
service public 2016-2020 et la 2020-2024
tel qu'elle a en cours d'exécution 2023
pardon dès qu'elle a en cours
d'exécution aujourd'hui
ont été notifiés à l'Union européenne et
ont été travaillés en amont avec l'Union
européenne ce contrats n'ont fait
l'objet d'aucune remarque de la part des
services de l'Union européenne ils sont
parfaitement exécutés et conformes à la
réglementation et à la législation sur
les études
en ce qui concerne les contrats relatifs
au dossier maritime le contrat mise en
place à compter les contrats pardon on a
cinq conventions de délégation de
service public une convention par ligne
les conventions de délégation de service
public mise en œuvre à partir du 1er
janvier 2023 ont été notifiés auprès des
services de l'Union européenne et ont
été travaillés en amont avec les
services de l'Union européenne comme je
vous l'ai dit précédemment les fois
précédentes certains contrats ont été
notifiés d'autres ne l'ont pas été du
fait de la courte vie des contrats d'une
certaine qualité à trois mois 12 mois 10
mois aujourd'hui nous avons une
stabilité à 7 ans des contrats de
délégation de services publics dans le
secteur de Paris
nos relations avec l'Union européenne
sont de bonnes relations qui sont
construites sur une confiance établie et
avec un travail de fond considérable de
la part des différents services que ce
soit état collectivités territoriale de
Corse office et transports et services
de l'Union européenne en prenant
travailler on travaille en partenariat
avec l'Union européenne sur le maritime
comme sur la
le dispositif vous serait-il
transposable à votre maire très
franchement il est difficile de me
prononcer là dessus car on ne connaît
pas les différentes composantes
spécifique pour voir ce qui peut être
transposable ce qui peut être adapté
pour ce qui ne l'est pas pour conclure
je dirais que l'accord dispose
aujourd'hui
une couverture en termes de contrat de
service public et d'obligation de
conforme aux attentes de sa population
et conformes aux intérêts et différents
territoires comme la présidence on a une
géographie spécifique et il nous faut
préserver ces territoires qui sont une
on a mis en place nous permet de
préserver cette richesse et de valoriser
ces territoires tenter un espace qu'en
termes sociales
le montant de dotation de continuité
territoriale
est aujourd'hui insuffisant il va
falloir non se pencher sur son
abonnement avec les éléments que je vous
ai que je vous ai fourni pour autant ils
m'ont correspond à un montant de juste
compensation
versez aux compagnies délégataires avec
un point important j'en veux pour preuve
le maritime avec le dernier contrat que
l'on a signé qui est la notion de
bénéfice raisonnable on peut vous donner
l'information dans la mesure où elle est
maintenant publique c'est que la marge
le bénéfice réalisé par les compagnies
délégataires de services publics et que
2,13%
. ce qui est le bénéfice raisonnable le
plus faible des compagnie maritimes qui
sont sous service public ou sous-ost
dans la salle méditerranéen et en Europe
les différents éléments bien sûr ont été
communiqués au service de l'Union
européenne
un dernier point pardon le tarif diaspor
dans vos questions donc sur ce tarif
on a une demande politique du Conseil
exécutif de travailler sur un tarif
diaspora ce tarif diaspora on y
travaille et on espère pouvoir le
présenter l'ordre de du prochain cahier
des charges pour le service aérien
dernier point de précision en ce qui
concerne la qualité de résidence comment
est-elle retenue elle est très
clairement définie par les délégations
de service public aérienne dans la
mesure où c'est que le trafic qui fourni
en partie de l'activité de nos
compagnies délégataires c'est la notion
de résidence fiscale en Corse la
résidence fiscale est ancienne de la
domiciliation fiscale au niveau de libre
la suite nous avons amené un travail de
fond avec les services de l'État avec
l'acier et nous délivrons une
accréditation présent aux résidents font
la demande de manière à ce qu'ils
puissent bénéficier de ce qui a indiqué
tout dérapage au regard de la best
tarifaire que l'on a appelé sur les
réseaux ensuite concerne le maritime
depuis 2023
les résidents Corses ne sont plus
éligibles au titre du taille président
dans le cas des conventions de
délégation de Facebook dans la mesure où
l'exception des besoins médicaux dans la
mesure où le transport de passagers est
garantit sous-obligation de service
public par la compagnie qui exerce
l'obligation de service public et comme
je vous l'ai dit précédemment ça
représente 85% des cas pour autant les
résidents corses qui souhaitent
emprunter les lignes de
bénéficie des tarés vu qu'on a une
cohabitation obligation de service
public d'élégation scientifique et bien
sûr cela ne donne pas droit à
compensation complémentaire au bénéfice
des compagnies des
ainsi conclu en intervention bien sûr je
suis redistribution pour toutes
questions que vous seriez nécessaire
je vous remercie d'avoir été aussi
précis finalement vous êtes passé à
travers tout le questionnaire merci
merci en tout cas et rapporteur et mes
collègues vous interpelleront par la
suite si nécessaire bien évidemment je
propose maintenant de passer aux
opérateurs sur un temps un petit peu
plus ramassé si c'est possible entre 5
et 8 minutes et on va commencer tout de
suite par Air France
bonjour monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs je vous
remercie de nous accueillir
alors
une précision en introduction
Air France opère cette délégation de
service public dans le cas d'une courte
entreprise avec la compagnie Air corsic
qui est représenté aujourd'hui
par le président de son directeur et
donc nous avons convenu que pour entrer
dans le la réponse à ce questionnaire
pour éviter des redondances je pense que
ça serait utile pour
pas perdre trop de temps nous vous
répondrions en commun et donc le
président de la Corsica se chargera de
ses réponses mais dans mon propos
liminaire je souhaite néanmoins revenir
sur deux points alors beaucoup de choses
ont d'ores et déjà été dites et je pense
dans une vision assez claire des enjeux
sur
[Musique]
c'est qu'à l'évidence
pour ce qui est des compagnies aériennes
nous j'aimerais dire que nous sortons
mais nous sommes continuons de traverser
une période particulièrement difficile
après deux années de
[Musique]
nous subissons aujourd'hui s'ajoutent à
un contexte déjà de grandes fragilité du
pavillon français le collectivement les
compagnies aériennes
françaises père d'historiquement des
parts de marché en France depuis de
longues années
parce qu'elles exercent leur activité
dans un contexte qui n'est pas favorable
particulièrement en France et donc il
est important de mesurer
dans les échanges que nous avons
aujourd'hui et les et dans le réflexions
que vous pouvez avoir sur le les enjeux
futurs de desserts que ce soit outre-mer
ou pour tout autre
zone géographique effectivement que le
les problématiques économiques
auxquels fait face le transport aérien
sont réels et
on impact sur nos activités qu'elle soit
dans un cadre de marché ouvert ou dans
le cadre de délégation de service public
comme c'est le cas que nous abordons
particulièrement aujourd'hui voilà donc
je ne vais pas répéter des choses qui
ont des plus des choses qui ont déjà été
dites ou
répondre par anticipation à ce que
pourra dire monsieur béréni dans un
instant mais voilà les points sur
lesquels il me semblait utile d'insister
à l'ouverture et comme ça j'espère avoir
un petit peu rattrapé du temps que nous
pour laisser du temps au dialogue voilà
merci à tous merci Monsieur Gomez
monsieur béréni vous avez la parole
oui je vous remercie
mesdames et messieurs mais sénateurs
sénatrices présidents et Présidente
c'est vrai que je vais avoir assez peu
de choses à rajouter ce qui a été dit
pour mémoire donc Air Corsica société
d'économie mixte créer il y a 33 ans
aujourd'hui délégataire des conventions
de service public sur
huit lignes que l'on dira de Bor à bord
entre les quatre aéroports et ceux de
Marseille et Nice et co délégataire dans
le cadre donc d'un groupement avec nos
collègues et amis d'Air France pour les
quatre lignes entre l'aéroport de Paris
Orly et donc les quatre aéroports corses
nous avions bien eu votre questionnaire
du 5 janvier je dirais que la totalité
des réponses a été apportée par les
interventions précédentes je n'ai donc
rien de plus à ajouter si ce n'est de me
tenir disponible aussi de nouvelles
questions
je vous remercie
merci Monsieur Virginie simplement
rappeler pour les tous les intervenants
en fait la délégation est évidemment
preneuse de vos retours par écrit des
différents questionnaires chacun en ce
qui vous concerne voilà pour la pour le
bon la bonne rédaction du rapport donc
voilà ce qui explique que dans cette
audition on peut passer assez vite au
travers de de cette de cette trame qui
vous a été adressée et geste maintenant
la parole à Monsieur Vilanova
par contre votre micro est débranché
monsieur je pense
non mais ça arrive je vous rassure
et vous restez toujours ébahis et muets
alors moi ce que je vous propose c'est
on va vous laisser le temps on va vous
laisser le temps de vous déconnecter de
vous reconnecter ça va peut-être régler
le problème et on passe si vous le
voulez bien monsieur Reverchon puis on
reviendra vers vous dès que vous serez
le connecter monsieur Reverchon qui lui
par contre est au téléphone sauf erreur
monsieur Reverchon est-ce que vous nous
entendez
bah écoutez on va simplement attendre
que Monsieur Vilanova se reconnecte
avant de passer la parole au rapporteur
parce que Monsieur visiblement monsieur
Reverchon de la Méridionale qui devait
nous rejoindre par téléphone lui aussi
visiblement quelques difficultés pour
nous
pour nous rejoindre
à vous avez en plus dans la salle de
visioconférence ici au Sénat un bruit de
fond peut-être que vous entendez de chez
vous voilà qui est tout aussi agréable
pour vous pour nous je vous rassure et
qui correspond à un perçage de mur en
béton ce qui vous donne des sensations
vraisemblablement donc ce qui donne une
sensation assez étrange mais voilà c'est
pas super agréable on va essayer de s'en
accommoder ah Monsieur Vilanova
bienvenue à nouveau parmi nous et vous
avez la parole
je vais essayer de reprendre les points
assez rapidement concernant le maritime
donc pour reprendre votre tram nous nous
sommes il y a 5 lots un lot par porte
tout cela au départ de Marseille le
périmètre a été défini préalablement
nous sommes adjudicataire de trois lots
seuls et de un lot en partenariat avec
nos collègues de la Méridionale
la modalité globale vous avez compris
vous êtes une structure en deux niveaux
la première c'est les obligations de
service public vous n'avez pas droit de
venir desservir l'accord
uniquement pendant la saison c'est ça
que définit les obligations CS publiques
c'est pour éviter qu'il y ait des gens
qui viennent uniquement en profiter de
la VAN estivale l'été et qui soit pas
l'hiver donc l'accord soit isolé l'hiver
et qui est personne qui et qui est
beaucoup de monde qui viennent l'été
avec une vision purement économique il y
a une il y a donc un niveau
supplémentaire qui considère qui fait
qui fait le socle d'agrégation de
service public ou donc la continuité de
Corse décide que on doit les trois jours
par semaine dans ce qu'on appelle des
portes secondaires et tous les jours
dans les ports principaux ça veut dire
que pour assurer la continuité
territoriale notamment en
approvisionnement de marchandises
le test de marché dit il faut aller par
exemple je prends toujours l'exemple du
lundi 2 février vous voyez il y a pas
beaucoup de touristes ou c'est plutôt
calme mais il y a une population qui
existe il faut essayer de limiter les
transports en Corse comme la définit la
présidente car c'est une île et donc il
faut qu'on il faut qu'on il faut que
vous alliez trois fois par semaine sur
les ports de Propriano Île Rousse
qui sont des portes secondaires
toute l'année ça veut dire que pendant
10 mois par an vous perdez de l'argent
et ensuite la deuxième chose qui est
définie la deuxième contrainte qui fait
l'objet de la délégation de service
public c'est les quantités de fret que
vous devez acheminer vers ces ports donc
ils sont étudiés il y a des quantités de
fraises qui sont définies pour les
portes secondaires comme les portes
principaux donc tout ça ça fait le socle
de ce qu'est la délégation de service
public et les opérateurs comme nous
calculent l'ensemble des coûts qui vont
avoir pour réaliser cette prestation
mettre en face de ça les recettes qui
vont avoir pour réaliser cette
prestation des recettes de mettre
linéaire de fret qui sont définies pour
la coïté des collectivités de Corse
c'est à dire que vous fassiez que vous
ameniez une remorque par an ou 2000
remorques par an quand vous payez le
même coût ça veut dire que le service
public fait que le transport entre la
Corse et le continent ne fait pas
l'objet d'une compétition entre les
acteurs tout le monde paye le même prix
pour une prestation
identique
les transports une remorque ou 1000
remorque par an donc quand je vais faire
la différence entre mes charges et mes
recettes mais c'est ça qui va faire le
besoin de service public
prorata une marche très faible telle
qu'elle a été définie préalablement donc
le mécanisme de compensation pour
répondre à votre question et celui-là
est-ce que ça tient compte
d'assaisonnementalité non c'est un c'est
un contrat annuel ça pour objet de enfin
plus rien duel ça pour objet d'assurer
pendant tout le long de l'année un
niveau de service public il n'y a pas
d'offre supplémentaire à la marche pour
le fret je dirais durant la saison
estivale on se rend compte que la saison
estivale est beaucoup plus forte pour
les passagers mais pour le fret elle va
un peu augmenter je dirais de 15 à 20%
par rapport à la à la saison hivernale
mais elle ne va pas doubler ou tripler
comme ça peut être le cas sur les
passagers donc oui on tient compte qu'il
est un peu plus de fret en été mais mais
finalement assez peu
les tarifs des résidences sont définies
par la coïti de Corse donc nous dans le
cadre de notre contrat de service public
on applique les décisions tarifaires qui
sont celles de l'Assemblée de Corse que
ce soit pour le prix du fret comme pour
le prix du tarif résident qui sont les
sujets concernés à même suite à résidant
fait l'objet d'obligation de la
République qui sont en partie concernées
par ces par ces sujets là
et il y a un sujet sur lequel je veux
insister c'est qu'avec le temps donc on
est pris un peu en étau mais c'est tout
naturel
entre
un besoin de service public qui devient
de plus en plus exigeant c'est normal
une volonté de contrôler le budget de ce
qu'est la desserte maritime de l'accord
pour le pour le la collectivité de Corse
la volonté de d'essayer de ne pas trop
augmenter les prix du fret
en face de tout ça parce que vous avez
bien conscience que si on augmente pas
les prix du fret il faut augmenter c'est
un effet comment dire de compensation il
faut augmenter le montant de la
compensation territoriale donc il faut
qu'on arrive à la fois avoir un prix du
frais qui soit le bon arrivé à rentrer
dans un budget qui rentre avec le cadre
du budget de la Corse et de la
compensation de continuité territoriale
et surtout les deux sujets qu'on va
devoir supporter pour les 15 ans à venir
ou 50 ans à venir c'est le coût du
carburant et les contraintes
environnementales donc vous avez à
droite les contraintes environnementales
à gauche le prix du carburant au dessus
le budget de la CTC et en dessous ce
qu'on peut faire payer
ce que peut accepter de payer que ce
soit le passager ou le
transporteur de Fred donc c'est ce cadre
là qui va qu'il faut arbitrer ou il y a
une impression qui vient un petit peu de
partout pour arriver à
à avoir le montant de compensation le
plus juste possible dans les cas
des règles européennes tenant compte de
ce que peut payer ce que doit payer dans
le cadre du principe même de la
continuité des territoriale le
transporteur et ce qui est acceptable
pour la région Corse donc c'est ça qui
fait l'objet de toutes les discussions
entre nous quand nous quand nous quand
nous répondons un appel d'offres et nous
et nous et nous et nous essayons de
faire la meilleure possible donc la
contrainte d'environnementale ce que je
voulais vous dire elle sera de plus en
plus importante et c'est ça qui va nous
forcer sûrement parfois à revoir nos
méthodes de pensée à faire sûrement
évoluer ce contrat dans le temps parce
que année après année la contrainte
environnementale sera de plus en plus
importante en synthèse si vous voulez
nous on ne fait qu'appliquer
la volonté politique de la collectivité
de Corse sur sa desserte maritime dans
le cas du service public elle s'exprime
à travers un cahier des charges à
travers des étapes publiques et après
une définition de ce que doit être le
service public et on est notre but c'est
de donner la meilleure réponse
logistique à cette volonté politique
c'est pas moi qui décide des rotations
c'est pas moi qui décide du prix
moi j'essaie de voir dans le cadre qui
est fixé qui a fait l'objet d'une étude
de marché quelle est la meilleure offre
que l'on peut donner à ces contraintes
là voilà comment je peux résumer
globalement ce qu'est actuellement et
comment est-ce qu'on essaie de procéder
dans le cadre de la délégation CS
publique sur la partie maritime
merci monsieur je ne sais pas si vous
pourrez m'entendre parce que les
vibrations et les travaux en façade
continue au Sénat on essaye de leur
demander une petite suspension le temps
nécessaire à terminer notre audition ce
qui n'est pas encore gagné en tout cas
c'était pas encore fait donc on va
essayer de faire au mieux je l'espère je
vais poser la question monsieur
Reverchon de la Méridionale s'il a pu
nous rejoindre par téléphone ou pas
vous entendons Monsieur Vous AVEZ LA
PAROLE
parler aussi fort vous le pourrez enfin
faites de votre mieux on essaiera
je vous prie de m'en excuser bon
beaucoup de j'ai entendu tout ce qui a
été dit et beaucoup beaucoup de choses
ont été dites auparavant et je ne vais
pas revenir dessus donc nous sommes
présents sur la Corse depuis 1936 la
continuité territoriale est un concept
qui a été mis en place en
1976 dans un premier temps dans des
mécanismes de gré à gré avec l'État puis
avec la collectivité de de Corse et et
c'est en fait la libéralisation du
cabotage européen vous m'entendez
oui monsieur voilà parfait excusez-moi
c'est la libéralisation du cabotage
national donc maritime qui en 2002 a
changé le dispositif et à déboucher sur
un mécanisme de dégagation de service de
délégation de service public donc qui
est actuellement en cours et qui vient
de repartir pour une durée
significative de de 7 ans au 1er janvier
donc de cette année
pour ne pas revenir sur ce qui a déjà
été explicité je voudrais souligner un
certain nombre de points le maritime est
un peu est un peu spécifique
ce que ce qu'il y a dans la délégation
de service public c'est en fait un
service qui est demandé c'est donc ça a
été rappelé toute l'année sur les ports
principaux de Bastia et de et d'Ajaccio
trois fois par semaine sur les ports
qu'on appelle le départementaux la
différence par rapport à l'aérien c'est
que on est
avec des navires c'est-à-dire des des
outils qui sont très chers d'abord 150
millions d'euros pour un navire neuf à
peu près qui sont qui sont très chers
qui nécessitent donc des durées
importantes pour pouvoir être amorti et
qui et qui sont spécifiques on n'est pas
dans le cas de l'aérien ou nous avons
des moyens qui sont un peu standardisés
qui peuvent se déplacer facilement dans
le maritime c'est directement adapté en
tout cas pour ce qui est du rouliers à
passagers qui est le système
nautique qui est en place donc sur la
desserte de la Corse qui sont
directement adaptés aux besoins je pense
en particulier au métrage de fret le
fret étant maintenant j'allais dire le
socle principal donc du du service
public le passager les temps que plus
marginal et concerné donc par les
obligations de services publics donc
nous sommes avec des des outils
particuliers en plus ces outils il faut
les les arrêter tous les deux ans et
demi pour par la technique qui sont
d'une durée de 5 semaines environ et
pendant ce temps là faire en sorte que
il y ait une continuité de service
public qui soit qui soit assuré avec
encore une fois des serres journaliers
journalières ou tri et hebdomadaire donc
des ports des déports
qui sont ça est déjà été soulignés
complètement dépendants de de la
métropole en particulier pour ce qui est
de l'approvisionnement en marchandise à
la fois de l'économie et des de la
population résidente voilà donc les les
sujets donc qui sont à l'heure actuelle
très important pour nous et d'autres
compagnies en particulier sont les
questions environnementales ou on a on a
développé de nouveaux de nouveaux
systèmes de collection électrique des
navires nous navires peuvent être
connectés quand ils sont dans les ports
et donc avec une émission donc qui et
nul de polluants que ce soit des oxydes
d'azote de soufre ou
des particules et on a équipé un non
navires d'une d'un filtre à particules
qui qui lui aussi en pleine mer évite
tous les tous les rejets donc polluants
c'est quelque chose qui est pour nous
essentiel qui d'ailleurs est prévu dans
le cahier des charges comme un des
critères de jugement des offres qui sont
proposées donc par par les camps les
candidats la prochaine échéance le
premier prochain enjeu c'est bien sûr la
question des carbonation qui elle pose
des questions plus importantes encore
plus délicate que celle de du traitement
donc des fumées des des moteurs et des
générateurs
voilà ce que je voulais dire très
rapidement
en rajoutant pas redisant pas un certain
nombre de choses qui ont été excellente
précédemment
merci merci à vous je vous cache pas
qu'on a eu un peu de mal à complètement
comprendre tous les propos dans la
mesure où les vibrations sont devenus
plus intenses et donc plus forte ici non
mais vous ne vous excusez pas c'est nous
qui nous qui sommes désolés pour tout le
monde donc on essaye de faire au mieux
je vais quand même maintenant laisser la
parole à deux rapporteurs qui eux aussi
feront au mieux
[Musique]
bonjour je sais pas si vous ne nous
entendez
oui
désolé pour les conditions ça ne
ressemble pas au Sénat mais qui est une
maison assez lisse et conviviale mais
merci beaucoup pour toutes ces
explications vous comprenez le sens de
notre dimanche nous sommes des
territoires pour la plupart insulaires
en dehors de de la Guyane éloigné de la
France avec des rapports obligés
légitime au quotidien nous par exemple
parlementaire on en sait quelque chose
on voyage régulièrement sur des milliers
de kilomètres
et puis les les relations sont rendus
nécessaires par plein d'éléments y
compris celles que vous avez ce que vous
avez évoqué qui relève de la prise en
charge de la santé on ne peut pas avoir
sur tous les territoires une offre
complète de soins et c'est régulièrement
que des personnes doivent quitter leur
territoire d'origine pour aller se
soigner quand un certain nombre
d'affections
en France je vous prends un exemple
comme ça pour l'anecdote pour le pays
qui me concerne le plus la Martini en ce
moment nous sommes en panne d'ophtalmo
il reste plus que trois ophtalmo
opérationnels sur sur l'île et vous
imaginez bien que avec une population un
peu comme la course qui est
vieillissante et bien les besoins en
soins
ophtalmologiques sont nombreux et
beaucoup de personnes doivent quitter la
Martinique pour aller se soigner en
France dans des centres
spécialisés je vous passe le reste les
cancers particuliers et tout donc on
efface à une difficulté pour des
populations qui souvent ont départ
important de personnes qui vivent en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté autrement
dit prenez un billet d'avion relève de
l'exploit financier en ce moment il faut
savoir que en haute saison puisque à
l'inverse de la France pour nous la
haute saison c'est la saison
pour la France
un billet d'avion va vite dépasser les
1000 euros en classe économique donc il
est important que nous puissions
restituer une certaine équité c'est très
bien que on pourra désormais s'appuyer
sur la jurisprudence Corse puisque
souvent on nous a fait ressortir oh là
là l'Union européenne sera pas d'accord
oh là là il y aura telle est tel
problème et là on se rend compte que il
y a le champ des possibles et énorme et
que l'Union Européenne j'ai entendu
plusieurs fois les interlocuteurs en
particulier Monsieur le Directeur de
l'ETC dire que Léo la suite est bonne
aussi bien avec le gouvernement français
qu'avec l'Union européenne donc merci de
toutes ces explications on sera encore
plus à l'aise pour dire que c'est
possible et je pense que je le disais
offre au président pour la boutade je
crois que l'État va commencer à craindre
ce rapport de la délégation
merci de toutes ces explications
j'aurais deux questions pour vous
comment ça s'est passé au début parce
que je vois que
l'antéyorité de cette DSP de cette de
cette dispositif de continuité ou au
monde aux années 70 comment tout cela a
pris quels ont été les difficultés que
vous avez rencontré au début puisqu'on
voit maintenant que c'est un long fleuve
tranquille vous en êtes aujourd'hui avec
lamer une dotation supérieure mais le
dispositif fonctionne comment tout cela
est né comment ça a commencé et la
deuxième question
concerne une réponse qui nous est
souvent faite c'est que éventuellement
des dispositifs de continuité
territoriale aurait opéré les principes
de concurrence si je prends l'exemple de
la Martinique nous sommes des servis par
3 accompagnés aériennes aujourd'hui
concernent Corsair tiens clin d'oeil
et un Caraïbes et en France et on nous a
toujours répondu que ah oui si on
mettait en place une dispositif encadré
il y aurait des distorsions de
concurrence comment vous voyez les
choses et comment tout cela peut être
comment pourrait répondre à ces à ces
arguments qui me paraissent là aussi un
peu facile merci beaucoup
merci merci aux différents intervenants
effectivement pour la présentation de
votre dispositif sur la constitué
continuité territoriale en Corse ou
globalement on ressent qu'un certain
satisfait sites sur sur le service rendu
aux résidents en Corse moi j'aurais une
question en complément qui va dans la
continuité de ma collègue rapporteur sur
la situation par a commencé vécu par
rapport à la
au système concurrentiel et puis est-ce
que vous pouvez préciser un petit peu
qui sont les les personnes éligibles aux
tarif et ce qui est des politiques de de
quotas de déplacement ou c'est cette
illimité ça pourrait être illimité par
rapport à des problématiques de santé
bien sûr mais est-ce que c'est illimité
pour pour tout par en fonction des des
âges où est-ce que c'est une prise en
charge totale ou est-ce que il y a des
un pourcentage de réduction enfin est-ce
que vous pouvez à peu préciser les les
modalités
tarifaires et puis la question je crois
n'a pas obtenu de réponse sur le les
tarifs préférentiels sont-ils toujours
plus avantageux que les tarifs
commerciaux dans des périodes où on sait
qu'il y a une volatilité
des prix
dans un contexte où vous l'avez dit
également
les prix du carburant et les contraintes
environnementales liées adaptation au
changement climatique est nécessité de
la décarbonation font partie aussi des
eneux de la mobilité aujourd'hui que ce
soit vers la Corse que ce soit en France
ou que ce soit de la France vers les
outre-mer merci
la parole cirque circule librement donc
il suffit que l'un d'entre vous ou l'une
d'entre vous en l'occurrence oui
monsieur
[Musique]
oui sur les tarifs je voudrais quand
même préciser qu'au-delà de la valeur du
prix du billet il y a deux paramètres
qui sont essentiels c'est d'une part le
stock de siège qui est qui est alloué
et deuxièmement ce sont les possibilités
de modifier
il faut savoir que le tarif résident
Corse mis en place dans le cadre des
conventions de négation de service
public dont nous sommes délicataires est
un tarif que nous appelons dans le
langage de l'aérien full Flex totalement
flexible il donne accès à l'intégralité
de la capacité des lignes y compris
jusqu'au dernier siège disponible
d'autre part il est interne entièrement
modifiable autant de fois que le client
le souhaite
et il est même annulable sans frais
jusqu'à deux heures avant le départ
et
on sait très bien qu'à chaque fois que
l'on compare des tarifs on a tendance à
de comparer que le prix parfois même
d'ailleurs sur deux lignes différentes
un prix promotionnel qui pourrait être
fait par un opérateur en très basse
saison comparé avec un prix de haute
saison pour un autre ce qui rend la
lecture très difficile mais je tiens
aussi à préciser qu'à chaque tarif est
associé un stock de siège et quand
l'occurrence en ce qui concerne le
tariferait des résidents corses c'est
l'intégralité des stocks et sur tous les
vols qui sont disponibles pour ce tarif
quel que soit le moment où on réserve et
d'autre part il y a aussi pour chaque
tarif
un certain nombre de contraintes ou non
c'est ce qui fait la flexibilité et je
crois qu'il est très important de
rappeler donc le tarif résident Corse
associe l'intégralité je dirais de cette
souples
qui est normalement celle qui s'applique
au plein tarif merci
de répondre à la présidente
donc tout d'abord en ce qui concerne la
question relative au début de la mise en
œuvre
du cadre continuité territoriale
je crois qu'autour de cette table à part
Monsieur Robert Jean de La Méridionale
aucun d'entre nous n'avait vécu la mise
en oeuvre pour autant on a on a les
références au passé à travers les divers
contentieux et des diverses discussions
qu'il y a eu pour construire le service
public que nous avons aujourd'hui comme
cela a été rappelé au tout départ le
service public était accordé à
l'éducation a été accordée par l'État à
des compagnies
la procédure de
mise en
page c'est les compagnies en place qui
bénéficiaient
des conventions de délégation de cette
publicité il est également bon de
rappeler
cette période-là
les directives communautaires n'étaient
pas encore en place à 1000 2008 pour
l'aérien et la 84
pour pour le maritime donc il y avait
une grande liberté de de choix et on le
comprend encore ensuite les choses sont
corsées par l'arrivée d'opérateurs
concurrentielle sur le secteur maritime
avec les conséquences que ça a eu en
termes de contentieux et de condamnation
de l'autorité des vivantes en
l'occurrence la collectivité de Corse
qu'il en est dernière à payer 130
millions d'euros d'indemnités un
opérateur privé pour la délégation de
salles juridique qui couvre la période
2007 2007 2013 donc ça a été ça a été et
c'est encore un chemin chaotique c'est à
dire que nous ne sommes pas
venant d'un fleuve tranquille nous
sommes le long d'un fleuve et d'un maire
qu'il faut sans cesse surveiller à
travers les évolutions juridiques
économiques avec l'arrivée possible de
différents opérateurs sur l'aérien comme
sur le maritime et par voie de
conséquences c'est permanentes de ce que
nous avons et de ce que nous souhaitons
préserver pour autant nous ne pourrons
le préserver que dès lors que l'on
démontre qu'il y a un besoin de service
public qui n'est pas satisfait
pour les attentes de la population la
clé de route elle est là
si on ne fait pas les études de besoin
de sa république si on définit pas nos
attentes très clairement et c'est ce
qu'a fait le Conseil exécuté tant pour
le maritime que pour l'aéro si on passe
de ça et tu te besoin de service public
démontre que pour tout ou partie il y a
des opérateurs privés qui peuvent le
satisfaire la délégation d'obligation
céleste publique existe la délégation de
ces types n'existe pas donc pas avoir de
conséquences il y a un travail
considérable à effectuer qu'en durant la
vie du contrat pour respecter le contrat
que lors du renouvellement est l'orgue
intervient le terme de contrat soit pour
relancer une procédure de délégation de
relancer pour tout ou partie donc ça
c'est un point qui ne faut pas perdre de
risque un travail de longue haleine
c'est un travail quotidien d'où la
nécessité de tisser un lien très fort
avec les autorités qui contrôlent et qui
valide c'est à dire l'état au niveau
régional et au niveau national il y a le
SCE le service du Premier ministre
qu'auprès de l'Union européenne
essentiellement avec la DG la DG
Concurrence
ensuite en ce qui concerne les questions
relatives à la tarification
ce directeur des Corsica a parfaitement
répondu à la différence
de se terminer la tarification
résidant arrive et en termes de qualité
de service je reviendrai sur l'octroi
qui peut en bénéficier
comme je l'ai mentionné précédemment
mais on peut aller plus loin dans
l'explication
depuis 2020 depuis la nouvelle
délégation de service public aérienne
mis en place à partir du 1er avril 2020
seul bénéficie de résident les personnes
ayant le résidence fiscal encore c'est à
dire que la personne qui vit encore 6
mois de l'année ou trois mois de l'année
ou huit mois de l'année mais qui n'a pas
sa résidence fiscale en Corse ne peut
pas bénéficier du tarif président
[Musique]
des conventions de délégation célestes
publiques ne rendent plus éligibles le
résident au titre des lignes de services
publics vu que le besoin en passagers
est couvert par un concurrent et là j'en
viens à la notion de
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on a un secteur parfaitement
concurrentiel en ce qui concerne le
maritime c'est-à-dire que l'essentiel du
trafic qui ne veut pas être couvert
en termes de fret c'est le fondement
même du principe de conduite
territoriale qui ne peut pas être
couvert par l'opérateur privé est
couvert par la convention de délégation
de CESU sur le passage des maritime à
l'exception du passager résidant médical
le besoin est satisfait par un opérateur
privé sous obligations
donc un service passager compensé n'est
pas éligible au titre des conventions de
délégation celles-ci et cela où on voit
vraiment à la cohabitation entre le
secteur concurrentiel et le secteur des
volumes au service
des tarifications
préférentielles Monsieur le Directeur
des Corsica répondu sur ce point donc je
n'y reviendrai pas mais il est important
de souligner de contrairement au début
de la mise en oeuvre du service public
nous n'avions pas de secteur
concurrentiel aujourd'hui dans le
maritime en un secteur conférenciel qui
nous oblige à être parfaitement conforme
à la directive qui s'impose à nous en
termes de marché
est-ce que vous m'entendez
oui oui
donc juste un petit complément les
tarifs sont des tarifs
maxima donc et à côté on a bien sûr des
tarifs dans le maritime puisqu'il y a
une concurrence il y a pas du tout de
monopole dans le maritime on a des
tarifs qui sont des tarifs entre
guillemets commerciaux donc on module en
fonction de la période de l'année et de
et des affluences donc les tarifs qui
qui sont proposés les tarifs maximum ne
conservent pour le passager que les
résidents donc au travers en particulier
des eaux des OSP comme ça a été signalé
précédemment juste deux mots quand même
l'historique comme la question a été
posée tout à l'heure
la continuité territoriale elle a été
créée en 1976 sous l'origine donc du
président Giscard d'Estaing donc
pourquoi elle a été créée parce que le
service à l'époque ne donnait pas
satisfaction à la fois en termes de
fiabilité et de qualité de qualité de
service si vous vouliez partir en Corse
l'été il fallait réserver dans la
première semaine de janvier quoi au
moment où s'ouvrait les ou s'ouvraient
les réservations donc il y avait des
queues au point de vente enfin c'était
infernal et et la séparation était
complète entre la partie
j'allais dire des passagers qui étaient
effectués par des séries et et la partie
et la partie fret c'est des cargos qui
des cargo purs qui à l'époque des
servettes donc la Corse et donc en 76 le
système de continuité territoriale a été
créé d'abord dans un premier temps avec
des négociations tous les 5 ans avec
donc les deux entreprises qui étaient
présentes à l'époque seulement sur la
desserte la SNCM et la Méridionale et
qui avait donc
[Musique]
des des contrats qui étaient qui étaient
passés et progressivement ce qui s'est
détaché dans la conception de ce système
de continuité territoriale c'est le fait
de j'allais dire de demander à la fois
un service pour pour le fret et les
passagers aujourd'hui ce service il est
effectué par les mêmes navires et les
normes avantages de ce genre de système
c'est qu'il a permis une des certes
quotidienne c'est-à-dire une qualité de
service très très importante
les certes quotidiennes elles n'étaient
que pour le fret à un moment donné et
c'est dans 2002 quand tu as démarré le
système on a commencé en 90 à la fin des
années 90 à avoir des navires qu'on
appelle des navires mixtes qui
transporte à la fois des passagers et du
fret jusqu'à 2000 mètres linéaires 170
remorques par exemple ou et typiquement
500 passagers à peu près ce qui a ce qui
a permis encore une fois une
amélioration absolument considérable de
la qualité de service qui avait souhaité
par l'autorité organisatrice des
transports donc l'état dans un premier
temps ensuite la collectivité de Corse
voilà ce que je voulais simplement
rajouter
ais volontiers sur la remarque de Madame
la reporte
sur justement le long fleuve tranquille
ce n'est pas un long fleuve tranquille
d'autant plus que nous sommes dans une
époque justement qui est
particulièrement compliquée et je l'ai
rappelé sur les différentes crises
successives que nous devons en tout cas
voilà il faut vraiment que nous fassions
fassent le plus possible surtout dans un
secteur qui évolue particulièrement vite
et je voudrais notamment revenir sur la
fameuse dotation de continuité
territoriale et exceptionnelle que nous
avons eu et que nous avons eu à négocier
de façon très très importante juste ne
serait-ce que par rapport à au caractère
inflationniste de l'énergie et du coup
des carburants ce sont 33 millions
supplémentaires qui sont à destination
de la collectivité territoriale de Corse
pour pouvoir assurer justement
le surplus de dépenses liées au
carburant donc à la compensation
carburant aussi bien pour couvrir les
frais du maritime que pour couvrir les
frais de l'aérien de cette année donc
c'est à dire que ça va passer la loi de
finance rectificative pour 2022 ainsi
donc tous les crédits de paiement les
autorisations d'engagement pour la
continuité territoriale de service
public sont majorés de 33 millions
d'euros mais c'est une dotation
exceptionnelle ce qui veut dire que
l'année prochaine il y aura une nouvelle
loi finance et donc il faudra de la même
façon
renégliger de la même façon si on a une
tendance qui vient se confirmer
justement du caractère inflationniste de
l'énergie et Monsieur le Directeur de
l'Office des transports très bien dit
c'est à dire que nous avons de plus en
plus de contraintes et de restriction
sur le plan environnemental avec la taxe
carbone avec la loi qui m'a résilience
ce qui veut dire que ce qui laisse
présager en tout cas que la tendance
sera forcément avec des augmentations de
compensation au niveau du carburant et
au niveau des des différents éléments
qu'on devra prendre en considération
dans la compensation qui fera partie
donc du service public et qui est mais
complètement indépendant de notre
volonté étant donné que c'est vraiment
le caractère général de ces
tarifications de cette taxation nous
sommes une île nous n'avons pas
l'alternative ferroviaire nous n'avons
pas l'alternative routière et que donc
du coup il faut prendre en considération
aussi les spécificités de l'insularité
rien que par rapport à ce point-là donc
ça fait partie vraiment d'un combat qui
est quotidien en quelque sorte pour
pouvoir vraiment faire et faire entendre
au gouvernement aux instances étatiques
mais aussi à la Commission européenne
les spécificités d'une île et la prise
en compte vraiment de l'insularité de
des difficultés des différentes
contraintes économiques et des
différentes contraintes avec les
concurrences qui ne sont pas parfaites
étant donné qu'on
en nombre limité donc voilà tout cela
n'est pas un long fleuve tranquille mais
en tout cas la relation a été avec la
Commission européenne et il y a eu un
gros travail de co-construction qui va
se poursuivre parce que là donc nous
avons fait la DSP 2023 2029 nous
attaquons cette année le travail de
préparation pour pouvoir mettre en place
le tracé des schémas aériens à l'horizon
de 2024 donc c'est à dire quels seront
les pour demain quels seront les
périmètres etc donc un test de marché a
été diligenté aussi par l'Office des
transports en début d'année dernière
pour pouvoir vraiment être échelonnée et
pour pouvoir avoir donc le besoin de
service public que nous allons analyser
de très très près voilà tout ça pour
pour dire que ça fait partie d'une
caractérisation que ce n'est pas un long
fleuve tranquille et que il nous faut
vraiment travailler co-construire et
avancer petit à petit car il y a
tellement de spécificités et vous le
savez de première enfin voilà vous
peut-être concerné également de par les
spécificités qui sont les vôtres qui
seront forcément différentes des nôtres
mais par contre il y a pas forcément de
transposition d'un cas à l'autre mais
des très communs que l'on va pouvoir
retrouver et qu'on va pouvoir
en tout cas argumenter et renforcer
comme nous l'avons pu nous avons pu le
faire pour le passager j'ai parlé du CHU
qui manque encore avec une offre de
soins qui est plutôt sur le continent
c'est ce qui nous a permis aussi de
caractériser certains flux et c'est ce
qui nous a permis aussi de ne pas passer
certaines lignes rouges que la
Commission européenne voulait nous faire
franchir voilà donc c'est pas très
important de maintenir un dialogue et
c'était vraiment un des éléments que je
voulais rajouter juste en réaction à
votre prise de parole avec les
spécificités pour les transports de
service public pour la continuité
territoriale et une DCT comme je le
disais les 33 millions d'euros si la
dotation de continuité territoriale
avait été indexée depuis 2009
normalement ne serait-ce que par rapport
à l'inflation etc nous aurions eu en
plus des 187 millions d'euros qui ne
sont versés annuellement à peu près un
donc 30 et quelques millions d'euros
supplémentaires sur la dotation de
continuité territoriale donc ça c'est
très très important à comprendre étant
donné que
de trouver que la vie a été stabilisée
depuis 2009 avec des taux d'inflation
qui sont très très importants est-ce que
vous trouvez que les prix de la passion
ont été stables stabilisés est-ce que
vous trouvez que le prix des produits de
première nécessité que nous trouvons
dans les commerces surtout dans les
commerces insulaires sont stables non
est-ce que vous trouvez qu'il y a une
inflation naturelle avec une
tarification de dotation continuité
territoriale plus adapté en fonction de
la démographie en sachant que depuis
2009 il y a eu donc une démographie
évidemment qui a augmenté donc un besoin
de des personnes qui vivent sur le sol
Corse qui ont leur résidence fiscale
encore qui a donc changé augmenté avec
donc un volume qui est normalement à
adapter
démographiquement de la même façon voilà
donc ça fait partie vraiment des points
que je voulais
apporter en plus pour les précisions de
vos différentes remarques
donc quand je disais long fleuve
tranquille c'était par rapport à nous
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes en
train de travailler les choses un peu
dans la dentelle vous avez passé les
écueils majeurs vous n'êtes plus dans le
rafting quoi nous on va commencer à
approcher le rafting et on ne sait même
pas encore où est la rivière donc c'est
quoi je disais que pour l'instant vous
êtes en train de
recaler les choses de les régler
d'exiger nous on a on parle de zéro
voilà
il faut bien partir de d'un point c'est
pas en tout cas
il a délégation en France de baliser le
circuit de rafting pour nous ramener à
bon port avec l'aide de nos amis
insulaires corses j'ai maintenant
peut-être laisser la parole à nos
collègues qui participent s'ils
souhaitent ou pas prendre la parole
à collectivité de Corse pente aussi au
budget par exemple le fonctionnement de
cette office est-ce que son
fonctionnement est à 100% pris en charge
par cette dotation c'est-à-dire il y a
bien le fonctionnement et un directeur
il doit avoir un conseil
d'administration des moyens mis pour les
contrôler tout est-ce que tout ça est
intégré ou est-ce que la collectivité
porte un supplément alors je vais vous
répondre très très succinctement la
dotation de continuité territoriale est
abondée vraiment pour couvrir
l'essentiel des différentes dépenses et
des différentes compensations pour
l'Office des transports de la Corse que
je préside depuis 2021 mais aussi
les différentes compensations comme je
vous disais exploitation carburant et
investissement pour la desserte
l'organisation de la desserte maritime
et aérienne de la Corse donc ce qui veut
dire que la collectivité de notre
absolument pas en compte sur quelconque
ne serait-ce que le fonctionnement de
l'Office des transports tout ça est
pourvu directement et après lever sur la
dotation de continuité territoriale bon
nous avons un petit office il s'agit
d'une petite équipe donc nous arrivons à
contenir c'est à dépenses qui sont
vraiment très très limités mais ça reste
vrai la dotation de continuité
territoriale qui vient subvenir à ses
besoins précis
je peux oui Marie-Laure
merci président bonjour à tous alors
n'étant pas insulaire puisque je suis
sénatrice de la Guyane donc qui est sur
un continent sud-américain la population
guyanaise se trouve confrontée au même
problématique que la Martinique qui vous
a parlé de déjà de l'offre de soins qui
est plutôt bancal chez nous puisque bien
souvent on évacue vers la Martinique et
donc ça veut dire que quand même la
Martinique Catherine vous êtes un peu en
avance quand même sur nous dans ce
domaine et moi je vais je vais
distinguer la continuité territoriale
par rapport au vol transatlantique alors
la Martinique à trois compagnies nous
nous disposons de deux Air France et Air
Caraïbes avec des coûts de billets en
économie à 1200 euros donc mettez vous à
la place des Guyanais qui veulent se
déplacer aussi bien pour étudier que
pour se soigner
et puis dire que on parle de continuité
territoriale aussi dans l'intérieur
puisque la Guyane a des communes qui ne
sont accessibles que par avion donc il y
a erguyan mais alors que c'est plutôt
c'est très Castan parce que souvent les
avions s'entendent souvent il y a des
problèmes par rapport à la climatologie
donc les habitants par exemple de
Maripasoula de papayestan de grands
sentis sont souvent bloqués chez eux
alors vous imaginez quand on parle de
continuité territoriale on parle
d'économie aussi comme vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure du du coût de des
matières premières et donc voilà alors
nous c'était surtout pour partager puis
prendre vos expériences puisque nous on
est encore pire que la Martinique que
Saint-Martin que Saint-Barth que
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon nous sommes
vraiment les dernières roues du carrosse
et je vous assure que la population
guyanaise commence à déjà révolté mais
de plus en plus parce que on voit ce qui
se passe autour de nous et nous sommes
bloqués nous sommes encore on va dire
entre guillemets à terme on est là on
peut pas voler on peut rien faire et
c'est compliqué pour nous voilà ce que
je voulais dire je vais vous faire
partager en tout cas les difficultés de
la Guyane
écoutez je ne crois pas qu'il y ait
d'autres crises de parole donc je vais
me permettre si vous le voulez bien de
conclure cet échange on vous remercions
toutes et tous de la qualité de vos
propos et vous dire que qu'en France on
est souvent et en tout cas quel que soit
la couleur du gouvernement favorable à
l'expérimentation je peux vous dire que
l'expérimentation Corse et l'expérience
que vous avez du dispositif que vous
avez mis en place va peut être une
source d'inspiration pour le
gouvernement s'il souhaite vraiment
récemment profondeur la notion de
continuité territoriale et on peut dire
il faut moi je fais ça admiratif de ce
que vous avez fait encore ça avec avec
le gouvernement et qui me qui me renvoie
d'ailleurs à ce que fait le Canada
souvent avec certains de ces territoires
ou la continuité est poussée à l'extrême
et où nos compatriotes ou les
compatriotes Canadiens ont vraiment le
sentiment que l'État prend considération
les notions d'éloignement et des doubles
insularité bien souvent est-ce qu'à
rappeler notamment ma collègue de Guyane
même si elle est continentale mais elle
vit entre guillemets une double fracture
de continuité territorial et donc nous
ne manquerons pas évidemment de nous
inspirer de ce que vous faites et de
suivre avec beaucoup d'intérêts les
travaux que vous menez je ne doute pas
que la délégation sera également son
inspirée les rapporteurs sont déjà tous
ont joué à l'idée de pouvoir creuser
plus avant donc cadre de ce rapport et
puis étant précisé que le gouvernement
va proposer d'ici la fin du premier
trimestre vraisemblablement une
évolution du dispositif de continuité
territoriale ultramarin et donc c'est
pour nous l'occasion peut-être de
questionner le gouvernement également
sur ces différenciation qu'il est
capable d'opérer avec une prise en
considération des thématiques
ultramarines en tout cas merci beaucoup
des apports très riches que vous avez
bien voulu nous faire et nous sommes
évidemment preneurs de vous
contributions écrites au regard des
questionnaires qui vous ont été adressés
et de toute autre contribution que vous
jugerez utile pour éclairer notre
rapport merci beaucoup et bonne fin de
journée à toutes et à tous
salut à tous au revoir
merci bonne journée
au revoir merci